Sinatra Frank baritone as he is listed
in Who's Who
will be the recipient of the Jean
Hersholt Humanitarian Award for 1971 the
distinction bestowed by the Academy on a
member whose special humanity brings a
special glow to all of us he has until
now managed quite well to keep his
humanitarianism out of the public view
and we're a little bit sorry to blow the
whistle on him but we do want to thank
him and to express our affection and
respect for a man who is without
question the current title holder in the
soft-touch division now we won't intrude
on that part of his life by quoting
examples from among his innumerable and
publicized charitable acts his gestures
of friendship and aid to people in need
of a helping hand to pick themselves up
and get back in the race he has a
special feeling for those kind he hears
about them and very often more often
than even his close friends know he does
something perhaps medical care is
provided money if that will do it a
personal visit a lift for the morale
whatever it takes
Frank does it but we are going to tell
you about a few extraordinary efforts
he's made on behalf of his fellow man
with these results on his world tour for
children's charities through his
appearances and contributions and
orphanage was established in Japan in
Hong Kong a Children's Hospital in
Israel a youth center in Athens and
nursery in Paris a home for crippled
children in Britain a home for blind
children in Italy the Boys Town of Italy
meanwhile back in the States
the Martin Luther King College in
Georgia in Los Angeles the Reese Davis
clinic and in Palm Springs the martin
anthony sinatra medical center over the
years he's given away his talent
literally hundreds of benefit evenings
appearances for schools hospitals youth
organizations medical research and in
particular for the benefit of minority
groups in 1953 this man was voted the
Academy Award for his moving performance
in a supporting role in From Here to
Eternity never were the members of the
Academy more prescient Supporting Actor
oh yes indeed no one within range of him
who has needed his support has ever been
refused it ladies and gentlemen a man
who pays his dues Frank Sinatra
this is truly an all-consuming thrill
for me tonight
over the years I've been part of the
awards wearing many different hats
performer emcee presenter
recipient but this is the top of the
moment of my little walk on in life you
might say and I've been doing a little
more thinking and contemplating these
days and I did 25 years ago
that's because how am what is known in a
vernacular as a retired man now he might
have read about that in your
neighborhood throw aways one of the
things I've been thinking about is why
you have to get famous to get an award
for helping other people and not being
facetious about it I've just been
thinking about it's true actually if
your name is John Doe and you work night
and day doing things for your helpless
neighbors what you get for your effort
is tired so mister mrs. doe and all of
you who give of yourselves to those who
carried too big a burden to make it on
their own I wants you to reach out and
take your share of this Jean Hersholt
Humanitarian Award
because if I have earned it so to have
you in fact your way of earning it was
harder than my way show business has
made it easier to me to spread a dab of
sunshine here and there I mean in show
business they pay quite well and being
the quiet conservative man that I am I
have invested a chunk of 3% and put the
dividends to work in that noblest of all
causes charity toward your fellow man
it's the only investment in the world
that pays a hundred percent dividend
anyway it's put a great big bundle in
here for me and I'd like to thank my
dear brothers and sisters of the Academy
for this joyous moment thank
you